きっしょ貴様
友達俺のじゃろこんにちははじめしゃ
ちょーですというわけで1週間ぶりに静岡
の3億円のうちに帰ってきました
[音楽]
久々すぎるあのコロナになって1週間療養
生活して1週間開けると本当にいろんな
スケジュールがぶっ飛んじゃってたまった
お仕事をたくさんやらせていただいていた
という1週間なんですけども久々に帰って
これたって
休んでる暇もなくちょっと気になることが
あったので今日それちょっと動画にしたい
と思って撮っておりますというわけで
3億円のうちなんですけども結構もう見る
場所がないもう見る場所がないというか
だいたいわかるでしょ皆さんも鬼ごっこと
かかくれんぼも結構したりしたんで地下に
大きな部屋があるとか実は天井裏になんか
人が入れるスペースがあるとか結構
いろんな場所も見尽くしたんでもうないか
なと思ったんですけども
あと一箇所あと一箇所だけ見てないところ
があるんですよそれどこか
屋上です屋上だけまだ行ってないし見ても
ないんですよかくれんぼのプロの人と
かくれんぼした時に隠れようとされたん
ですけども危険だということでNGにした
んですけどもじゃあ
安全だったら入っていいんじゃないかと
いうことで今回
満を持してしっかりと安全を確保した上で
ちょっと管理人と一緒に屋上の偵察に行っ
ていきたいと思いますマジで初めてなので
僕も何があるかわかんないんでちょっと
怖いんですけども
早速3億円の豪邸の屋上見ていきましょう
はい
というわけで早速屋上に行ってみるんです
けれども
[音楽]
これ
ハーネスですもう落ちるのだけマジで安全
も何もないもんだってなんもないなんも
ないこれでもしくどれが上行って良ければ
手すりとか置いても手掛ける場所とか安全
を管理して屋上コーナーを作れる可能性も
あるということなんですよ確かにね
絶景だろうね絶景だね
公園作りたいレベルに公園かとりあえず
また警察に行きましょうかよし行け
ましょう何もわかんないですね
足を通すようにしてます
[音楽]
はいというわけで準備完了しました
早速見に行きましょうか行っちゃい
ましょう
[音楽]
どこ行くんですかこれ
言えよこれよしじゃあ行きましょうか
行こうかある場所が
ここなんですよねはいはいはいはい
工事でさなんとかできるのかなというわけ
で今回ですね
三脚が持ってきておりますのででマジでも
初めてだよね
[音楽]
[拍手]
確かにそもそも開くここが錆びてる
ちょっと開かないので1回開けます行き
ますはい
行けそうなん
何これ何これ
水溜まったってたんだなんて
あーこれ水溜まってるじゃんここだー
マジで
いやいやいや待ってないこれなんかでも
あれだよね多分
九州在庫ちょっと
待って何を吸収してるはいもうすぐね屋上
ですちょっと行きますよし行きます
[音楽]
YouTuberってすごい仕事だなよし
行きますいらっしゃい
[音楽]
えー俺さぁ高いとこ食べないよ実は
実は俺もなんだよしっかり
怖い行きます
これ待って帰れる俺たち
はそうだね
[音楽]
なるほどね
マジで怖いよ
お願いします
[音楽]
すごいよ
すごいはいというわけで
屋上つきました
でっけよいやすごいねすごいちょっと
角行く時だけ危ないんでその時だけ
ちょっと安全に行こうはい
[拍手]
広くねめちゃめちゃ広いね
実質5階だね
静岡が一望できますよこれ一周していい
[音楽]
すごい
はいはいああれだね
向こうが今日は見えないけど富士山が私が
あるんですよ
赤塚に見える
[音楽]
つけれるところが
大地君でしかない
頼んだ最初の払っていきます
[音楽]
[拍手]
引っ張られてる
すごいねいやいやいやいやいやでもこれ
なんかもったいないなあもったいないね
もったいないなぁ何か置けって言われてる
ような広さほんとよちょっとねこう周りに
柵とかつければそうね
すごい広いところだからベンチとか持って
きてもらうありゃ
誤解にいるんだけどさあの2階にあるさ
チェア持ってきてもらっていいあと酒も酒
も持ってきて
すごいねいやもう絶景すぎる本当なんか虫
飛んできたんだけど
[音楽]
椅子どうしたおい
椅子どうした
やべえこれ
やべえわだって絶対いけんじゃない迷惑
かかんないじゃんこれよりか高い建物が
周りにないからねないね確かに
バーベキュー
ここだったかバーベキューはここだね
すごいよこの広さはこんなに広かったん
だっていういやこれ絶対なんか使えそうだ
と思うなはい今角に置いてるんですけども
見てこの広さもう
すごいぞ
はいどうですか屋上いやもうびっくりし
すぎたこれはすごいなんかさもっと
ごちゃごちゃしてるイメージだったんです
よね
空調の機会がいっぱい
ごちゃごちゃ置いてあって
思ったんですけど結構すっきりしてて
水先もいいから水も溜まってないとなんか
ねほんとたくさい作れば素敵な屋上できる
んじゃないかなともう
入り口があれしかないじゃん
最後見てなかった屋上今見て全然また改造
の余地があると思うのでここも何かの
スペースにしたいですねそうですねという
わけで3億円のうちはまだまだ進化し続き
ますのでぜひお楽しみに
ありがとうございます
[音楽]